divide simplifica la respuesta y
escríbela como número mixto aquí tenemos
una división de fracciones cuatro entre
dos tercios pero como ya hemos visto
dividir entre una fracción es lo mismo
que multiplicar por su recíproco
entonces esta división queda como 4 por
el recíproco de dos tercios y ese quien
es pues simplemente hay que intercambiar
el denominador por el numerador entonces
queda tres medios cuatro por tres medios
y esto ha que es igual bueno esto lo
podemos resolver de varias maneras una
es haciendo la multiplicación de
fracciones pero 4 no parece una fracción
pero sabemos que 4 es lo mismo que 4
entre 1 y ahora si esto ya lo podemos
resolver 4 por 3
12 y el denominador ponemos 1 por 2 2
y ahora hay que simplificar esta
fracción podemos hacerlo así 12 entre 26
y ya acabamos aunque también podemos
pensar de la siguiente manera el
numerador es divisible entre 2 y 12
entre 26 y el denominador lo podemos
dividir también entre 2 y 2 entre 2 es
una y nos queda 6 entre 1 que es lo
mismo que 6 aunque si te fijas
pudimos haber multiplicado desde el
principio porque porque tanto arriba
como abajo hay números que son
divisibles entre 2 fíjate en el 4 y en
el 24 es divisible entre 2 y 4 entre 2
es 22 también es divisible entre 2 y 2
entre 2 es 1 y entonces si multiplicamos
directamente aquí que nos queda 2 por 36
y uno por uno
es una y nos queda
6 que ya era lo que habíamos obtenido
ahora vamos a entender visualmente qué
es lo que está pasando es decir qué
significa cuatro entre dos tercios para
ello vamos a dibujar cuatro cajas 4
entonces dibujamos una caja
otra caja
aquí van dos cajas
tres cajas
cuatro cajas y vamos a dividir las cajas
en grupos de dos tercios de caja mira
vamos primero a dividir cada caja en
tres partes 1 2 3
1 2 3
y la última caja igual 1 2
3 y ahora vamos a hacer grupos de dos
tercios de caja es decir esta parte de
aquí y esta de aquí forman un grupo
luego esta parte de aquí y esta parte de
aquí forman otro grupo
otro grupo de dos tercios de caja esta
parte de aquí y esta parte de aquí
también forman otro grupo
estaré aquí y estaré aquí también forman
otro grupo de dos tercios de acá
esta y ésta
forman otro grupo
y por último nos queda este pedazo y
este pedazo que forman otro grupo de dos
tercios de caja y entonces contemos
cuántos grupos de dos tercios de caja
tenemos aquí tenemos uno dos
es decir tenemos seis grupos de dos
tercios de caja y teníamos cuatro cajas
espero que con esto te haya quedado
claro que significa dividir entre una
fracción